foreign
ER can establish him or herself as a
firm fan favorite due to the high
intensity of how they play the game or
just by plainly getting the crowd hyped
up every match but of course the
favorites don't always win AK is gonna
go home yo guys make some noise for you
to Hometown hero AK while they may not
have claimed the tournament trophy
they're captivating performance earned
them the true championship of the
crowd's hearts
chance we could get a journey hey guys
welcome to another Ocho TV special and
here are some players who didn't win the
tournament but won the crap
[Applause]
[Music]
here more pressure from Kokomo they are
about even a life what more he can do it
is
and he clearly takes it and that's gonna
put me
foreign
[Applause]
idle time
oh he caught up it's gonna be a lot of
damage
on to Grand finals jdcr
ings
and I hate to say this [__] damage where
did we get it on the wall and of course
oh they're cheering for Brian oh my God
he's gonna give it to him the murderer
Brian finally picked by me
and she beat around you should be able
to sit out here
wow
[Applause]
oh wow
you're trying to get to him 20 seconds
left what is about to happen this battle
is about to explode
he might get the wall here
moves on in a ridiculous wow again
thank you and the crowd just cheering
for me you guys can hear it for it again
2017 Make some noise
[Music]
that's another one
while standing four yeah
it's his name
oh God
oh man I would have did it
hold on with the rage yard overzugo to
move on he is going to get his Tech in
world to a final run back and it's gonna
be hell sweet I got one too damn sit on
it
I don't know
I like what I'm seeing the first round
the perfect so far the down two to try
to close out five step two not gonna
work
oh boy we doing this again
oh my God
okay
yo he's in big trouble checking the
trouble to get up stick oh does he have
dick
the second world to a champion is out of
the tournament oh my God this is not
looking good aroma in full control oh my
goodness yeah all sounds are bigger but
now here comes the risky stuff also he's
in big trouble that will be that all
done out of the tournament the Roma
moving on the aroma stand alive in the
tournament and you know one of the
things that he did and he made sure
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this is all the way to the walls
so close there it is garlanda takes game
one against Arizona it's gonna do a ton
of death oh god oh my god oh no
how does he keep getting away on rage
now what can he do what can he do that's
it good
straight against possibly the biggest
favor coming into this tournament arslan
Ash OH
Replay that BTS Starts Now rage
available for Katarina
carrier mixer
right there big damage
um
we're gonna be game number one
move
[Applause]
pressure
here we go rain thunder will be counter
it down two oh in the fall off but he
has the rage against over still a pixel
still looking and game one goes to
GarageBand can he make the comeback ring
Knight block
time
[Applause]
foreign
it's not over yet
tuck it off good interrupt ah counter
hit a bin that's young dig is
two to zero and move into losers fight
[Music]
oh my God just like I said that that
flash looking really yeah switch stance
one because the counter hit just looking
good for Coggin baru again you have to
be careful
I feel like he knew what was coming
everyone knew but what you got frost
side position what have you got for us
oh he's gonna he's gonna flip again oh
my God no swords
this [__] a pixel and a dream yeah
yeah
he stopped caring a while ago he can
hear us he's like you guys think you're
so smart
nice block that was a great Expendable
Race drive
good blocks oh my God
oh
spec really stood up oh my God oh my God
that's it
there goes the tournament for kage
models I musician stays alive
she's keeping him out with the Fireballs
now chilling oh man okay [__] listen to
me
nice we do he would get the wall break
closes his head out yeah
oh my God this is so sick
what are you doing what's going on right
now
I don't know
oh he tried no he blocks I like it oh my
God yo you have to be careful though
because
he's gonna do it
oh my God
okay let's win yeah that spin has been
helping him out so much especially when
he's back to the wall yeah he just he
had the radar for getting away from
danger oh my God the read on that Nick
jab right I just think right now this
flow is
[Music]
God damn
wall now
last chance to lose
I think he got two huge big levels
AK moving on
[Music]
red right now oh muscle Buster nice
break
over the rip Luke to the wall
oh my goodness okay while standing three
I like the
adjustments
and he had Rachel he's got the reasons
people's elbow let's go Little Monkey
Crazy
Mike you know what we want to hear
I smelled your groin
one more time
[Applause]
whoa
give it up bro let him know
like the world now you are here to play
Jim top Eight Episodes seven the latest
entry in the series and man it has been
a pleasure yeah
he should be able to get the follow-up
oh he went for the hard time oh my God
he's gonna do it he got the round one oh
my God
a reverse sweep this isn't gonna work
we're gonna need to get a stunt doubling
here I need a stun double in here oh my
god oh I love this guy Majin playing
possibly seeing it oh my gosh there it
goes
the damage here comes the corkscrew the
wall
let's go marching oh
oh
backing up backing up underneath
oh my God again he gets it
oh my God block that
yeah
and again
jdcr oh he gets it one more hit can do
it oh my God
Harris I can't believe what I'm seeing
any chance I know we want to take a
break later but man any chance we could
get a gurney I I'm gonna need some help
I need more water too guys yeah it's
adding up like crazy that should be it
that's gonna hurt big time and Majin is
in losers bracket about it oh my God oh
my God and he whipped it's the kill I
gotta give it up for this young man from
Tennessee though Standing Ovation for
the true legend the best King in the
universe
all right
hey did we miss anyone
just let us know in the comments and
also shoot us a message for suggestions
for future videos we'll see you next
time
[Music]
foreign